repasemos brevemente lo que hemos hecho
en vídeos pasados estamos trabajando con
transformaciones lineales que iban de rn
en rm y nosotros sabíamos que si el
vector x está expresado en coordenadas
estándar es decir respecto a la base
estándar de rn entonces su imagen se
podía encontrar como el resultado de
multiplicar una matriz por el vector x
por el lado izquierdo es decir tx era
igual a de x
esto lo representa vamos así si estamos
trabajando en coordenadas estándar
entonces x x la matriz a tenía como
resultado el vector de x ahora bien qué
pasaba si teníamos otra base para ir m
si tenemos una base alternativa para rm
entonces las coordenadas con respecto a
la base b
si tenemos el vector x expresado en
coordenadas respecto a la base b y lo
multiplicamos por una matriz de lo que
teníamos eran las coordenadas de la
imagen respecto a la base b es decir
este proceso acá abajo tenía
y tenemos una matriz de que directamente
nos daba la imagen las coordenadas de la
imagen respecto a la base ve además como
teníamos ave que era una base para el re
n podríamos definir la matriz de cambio
base que es simplemente una matriz cuyas
columnas son precisamente los vectores
de la base y entonces para pasar de las
coordenadas respecto a la base vean las
coordenadas estándar simplemente
teníamos que multiplicar en este vector
de coordenadas por la izquierda por la
matriz c y obtenemos las coordenadas
estándar y si por el contrario teníamos
las coordenadas estándar de un vector lo
multiplicamos por la matriz se inversa y
obteníamos las coordenadas respecto a la
base b entonces nosotros derivamos que
la matriz de esta matriz que hacía esto
tenía que ser igual a c inversa por a
por c básicamente lo que hace la matriz
de es directamente subir acá pasar acá y
bajar de nuevo
en el vídeo pasado trabajado trabajamos
con un ejemplo concreto en r2 teníamos
la transformación de drd2 en r2 dada por
tv x era igual a la matriz a era 3 - 22
menos 2 x el vector x y tomamos una base
alternativa para r 2 que era la base 12
y el vector 2 1
nuestra matriz de cambio coordenadas
entonces era esta y tenía esta inversa
entonces siguiendo esta fórmula debe
hacer igual hace inversa por a por c y
esto es lo mismo que menos un tercio por
la matriz 1 - 2 - 2 1 por la matriz 3
menos 22 minutos por la matriz 12 21 y
eso el resultado de todo esto vimos que
era menos 1 002 ésta era la matriz d
y dijimos que esta matriz de tenía este
efecto que producía esto así que ahora
vamos a checar esto vamos a ver qué es
lo que hicimos realmente tiene sentido
bien para checar que la matriz de
realmente tiene el efecto que deseamos
vamos a empezar con un vector x factor x
en r2 digamos vamos a usar el 1 menos 1
ese va a ser mi vector y lo primero que
tengo que hacer es encontrar su imagen
bajo la transformación t
ahora yo sé que me quebraron las cuentas
de este lado yo sé que te x
tx es igual a
a de x x x
y es precisamente esta matriz de aquí
así que esto es lo mismo que
33 - 22 - todos
multiplicada por el vector x
muy bien entonces cuánto vale te de uno
del lector te
de del vector
1 - 1
pues simplemente vale el producto de la
matriz
3 - 2 2 - 2
por el vector
si hago este producto de matriz vector
obtengo tres por uno es 3 más menos 2
pero menos uno que es 2
tres más dos que es 5
y luego 2 por 12 más menos 2 por menos
12 de nuevo así que el 2 más 2 6 4
así que tve keys vale
muy bien así que lo que tengo ahorita es
precisamente la parte superior de este
diagrama esta parte de aquí
voy a ahora
cuánto vale el vector x en la base b
con verde
cuánto vale el vector x en coordenadas
respecto a la base d
pues si recuerdan
si recuerdan tenían una fórmula que me
decía que el vector
es un vector ha expresado en coordenadas
respecto a la base b era igual a la
inversa de la matriz de cambio de base
por el vector en coordenadas estándar
así que en este caso la matriz de cambio
de base la inversa la matriz de cambio
de base es menos un tercio
vemos un tercio de esta matriz así que
el vector x en coordenadas respecto a la
base b
es igual a menos un tercio
multiplicado por la matriz 1 - 2 - 2 1
y eso multiplicado por el vector 11
ahora eso es lo mismo que menos un
tercio multiplicado por el vector uno
por uno es uno más menos 2 por menos uno
que es 23 menos 2 por uno es menos dos
más menos uno por uno
que serían menos 3
ahora multiplicó para al menos un tercio
y obtengo el vector menos 11
miren qué chistoso este vector el doctor
original era el 11 y este vector fue el
menos 11
bien entonces el vector x en coordenadas
respecto a la base ve que puedo poner un
distintivo
el vector
- 1
respecto a la base p
ahora bien
si lo que hay acá arriba este renglón
equivale a multiplicar por la matriz
así que ahora lo que tengo que hacer es
multiplicar por la matriz d
la matriz de que es está aquí
así que déjenme hago eso por acá
cuánto vale de multiplicada por el
vector x en coordenadas respecto a la
base b
pues eso vale la matriz de es la matriz
1 002
multiplicada por el vector
- 11
recuerden que esto está en coordenadas
respecto a la base y cuánto me da esto
pues sencillamente es menos 1 x menos 1
1 positivo
y 0 más o menos uno por menos 10 por 11
y luego 0 por menos 10 más 2 por 1 que
sería 2
y esto nos gusta en coordenadas respecto
a la base b
esto es entonces el vector
12 congelar respecto a la base ve
bien entonces aquí para pasar de este
vector a este otro lo que hicimos fue
multiplicar por la matriz de inversa
y si lo que decimos es cierto este
vector este vector debe ser igual
debe ser igual a las coordenadas del
vector trx
respecto a la base ve
y esto es cierto pues vamos a checar
vamos a checar rápidamente esto
quienes son las coordenadas del vector
del vector 54
respecto a la base
estamos en frentes
respecto a la base de
pues de nuevo es tengo que multiplicar
por la matriz de cambio de base inversa
así que es menos un tercio
recuerden que aquí tengo la matriz de
cambio base 1 - 2 - 2 1
para donde inversa la matriz de cambio
base
x el vector 54
así que esto es una más un tercio te
quiere
1 por 15 más menos 2 por 4 es 8 528
sería menos 3
el estrés
y luego tengo menos 2 x 5 es menos 10
más uno por cuatro que menos 10 4 que
sería menos 6
y ahora si multiplicó por el menos un
tercio
tengo 12
que es precisamente esto precisamente es
este vector así que si es cierto que si
multiplicó este vector por la inversa de
la matriz de cambio de base obtengo este
vector el 12 en otras palabras lo que
acabamos de ver
lo que acabamos de ver es que es
completamente equivalente primero a
convertir a coordenadas respecto a la
base de y multiplicar por la matriz d
llegar a este vector primero aplicar la
transformación y luego convertir las
coordenadas ahora esto no es una prueba
formal de la fórmula de acá arriba esto
no es una prueba formal de esto si
quieren la prueba tienen que ir al vídeo
pasado pero definitivamente demuestra
que esto funciona y bien quizás estoy
preguntando
quizás estén preguntando para qué sirve
esto
para qué sirve
pues
antes de contestar esta pregunta voy a
citar una cita de un maestro de álgebra
metros de altura la cita en inglés está
en inglés pero la voy a traducir
y un maestro le dijo uno de sus alumnos
que el álgebra lineal
el álgebra lineal
es el arte
es el arte de encontrar
encontrar
la base
adecuada
y esto es una cita muy bonita y lo que
significa es que en algunas bases las
matrices toman formas más simples por
ejemplo si comparan esta matriz a contra
esta matriz de pueden notar que esta
matriz es diagonal y entonces aplicar
esta matriz multiplicar por esta matriz
es muchísimo más sencillo noten que
simplemente lo que pasó fue que
multiplique la primera coordenada este
vector por menos 1 y la segunda
coordenada este vector por 2 y obtuve
este vector así que esta matriz es más
sencilla y eso es muy útil en problemas
en los que tienes que calcular
muchísimas veces o tienes que calcular
muy rápido imagínense que tuvieran que
aplicarle la transformación t a un
vector y luego a eso volverse y aplicar
la transformación p por lo que harían
sería multiplicar la matriz a por el
vector y a eso multiplicarlo a través la
matriz a ahora imagínense que tuvieran
que hacerlo a 100 veces entonces a
hacerlo con la matriz a sería muy
complicado pero hacerlo con la matriz de
sería relativamente sencillo así que en
problemas especialmente problemas de
computador
de computación es mucho mejor trabajar
con bases en las que las
transformaciones son más sencillas y
quizás tengan este problema de que no
tienen que convertir las coordenadas
pero realmente el esfuerzo que haces
para eso relativamente es poco relativo
a cuánta esfuerzo que tomaría hacer este
proceso cientos y cientos de veces así
que realmente esta sitio es muy cierta
el álgebra lineal es el arte de
encontrar la base adecuada